let me update you on the YouTube
advertiser boycott okay this is a
boycott that started up
nine days ago at this point and
overnight the david pakman show lost
99.5% of our YouTube revenue as a result
of a YouTube advertiser boycott
advertisers pulling money off of YouTube
because they felt their ads were showing
up next to controversial material and it
has had the the repercussion of ending
all YouTube revenue for the show this
represents nearly half of our total
revenue and we are in really really
rough shape right now has it gotten any
better this started on March 31st the
answer is no this is the latest chart of
YouTube revenue and as you can see here
35 cents Pat on on April 8th 2017 which
is roughly what the channel has been
making this entire time down from $6
before which which looks comparatively
high on this chart which is absolutely
and utterly insane so why is this bad
this is bad for many reasons number one
this is a boon for corporate media
because the money that these big
advertisers are pulling out of YouTube
they're going to spend it elsewhere on
advertising and it's going to go to
corporate media and that is why
corporate media is absolutely loving
what is going on here in addition to
that look at what's happening with
coverage of the serious strikes we did
this earlier in the show 17 of 20
newspapers that took an editorial
position on what's going on in Syria
we're partially or fully behind it this
is reminiscent of the Iraq war and the
timing of it with this YouTube ad
boycott that is crippling us is only
going to make it so that these pro
missile rah-rah-rah get behind the
president and his bombs mentality is
going to further spread so we have a few
different things that you can do in
order to help our show okay to make up
this revenue number one you can become a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership this is super easy
the
has been going on for a while we have a
coupon code I voted 17 if you want to
use it number two please make a
contribution on patreon patreon comm
slash david pakman show more about that
in a second three if you shop on
amazon.com go to david pakman.com slash
amazon before you shop everything you
buy will send us a 5 to 8 percent
kickback
number four if you are a YouTube read
subscriber which allows you to watch
youtube videos ad free watch our videos
figure out a way to create a playlist
where our videos are looping 24 hours a
day if a thousand people do that that
will force some revenue back to us
through the YouTube read system and
number five you can go to david
pakman.com slash gear we've got coffee
bumper stickers t-shirts and hoodies
available for you there and and you can
also do that the good news is the
patreon donors are accumulating this is
a cumulative process as of this morning
we will show you what patreon looks like
as of this morning we had 1104 patrons
1104 patrons we estimated that we were
receiving thirty to fifty cents from
each YouTube audience member if they
watched all of our videos every month so
with just $1 at patreon.com slash david
pakman show you are actually making up
for all the money we were losing from
from you as a YouTube viewer most people
can do a dollar and I encourage you to
do that at patreon.com slash david
pakman show also good news about
membership is a lot of people are
signing up there and you can go to david
pakman.com slash membership after
selecting your membership and clicking
the red signup button you will get to
page 2 of the membership sign-up process
and where the red arrow is if you're
watching you can input the code
I voted 17 and that'll give you a 40%
discount so let's do this thank you to
everyone who's contributed we are
starting to make up the lost revenue and
I hope you'll continue to help us there